even though everything is more expensive  now millions of americans are traveling  for memorial day weekend  aaa expects more than 39 million  americans will travel 50 or more miles  it's up about 8.3 percent from last year  in april alone government research  showed airfare costs surged more than 18  percent that's the largest monthly spike  ever  with all the extra commuters out there  aaa made a checklist so that you can  have a safe road trip make sure to  schedule vehicle inspection in advance  plan any maintenance needed check your  battery you know they die quicker out  here in the desert lay the last max two  years ensure that your tires are in good  condition and are rid of any road  gaiters which may lead to any blowouts  and finally check those fluid levels so  that nothing catches you by surprise on  the road if it will visit that is  aaa.com for more information